cliche of opening narration replaced by
its sinister cousin opening singing what
we already did the Disney logo with the
pink castle Jesus now we're doing
multiple logos per studio in front of
the film cute baby animal qualification
fulfilled also the director said I want
you to have that baby reindeer eat a
carrot so he will look like even more of
an asshole ice is stronger than a
hundred men unless you have a pickaxe is
anyone chaperoning this child this large
triangle window is a few to sleep
[Music]
animation princess magic Disney movie is
ago people Disney movie is a go for
launch
movie rips off the all the answers are
in some old mysterious book thing from
Buffy the Vampire Slayer this map looks
really unhelpful we interrupt this
animated princess movie to bring you
Galaxy Quest but don't worry I leave the
five you mean you have the power to
remove fun two powers that's for the
best
yeah because you don't have and never
will have the power to tell your sister
no when she asks you to do magic you
must learn to control it I know a guy
who teaches a summer class if you want
to enroll wait I know this room is huge
but they still had to share a bedroom in
this huge castle so does Anna really not
see Elsa for years the family never gets
together and eats dinner or anything
also why even bother erasing Ana's
memory if else is just gonna stay behind
a locked door the whole time this stunt
is actually more dangerous than any of
the ice game Zhanna and Elsa were
playing before girl with superpowers
dead parent cliche this is a superhero
movie look if she's freezing up the
entire room including the doors she's
leaning against then her sister would
definitely feel the cold and probably
also be leaning against an ice block and
not a door I bet they're absolutely
you do yeah if I were in a relationship
with this cartoon I'm probably still hit
it if she let me also this whole kingdom
went for over a decade without seeing
the princesses after the king and queen
died they just took the word of some
random castle Butler that the princesses
were alive and well and you could not
possibly grow up in this fucking
behemoth castle without knowing you had
eight thousand salad plates you an ac/dc
should have a discussion about wordplay
what does I mean that one um neo is a
Warner Brothers character so I'm not
sure how you think that would happen but
Princess has got a dream I guess or wait
did you mean Jet Li haha women in your
chocolate it seems like these gloves do
a good job keeping the ice from
happening so why did Elsa need to lock
herself in a room for all these years
this girl's motivation change from
hanging out with her sister to finding
true love in the blink of an eye this is
a princess right heir to the throne
not one person guarding her or keeping
an eye on her his kingdom is run by
idiots
since we find out Hans is a bad guy
later this little moment of him smiling
like he's a good guy while no one is
around is a bit of a cheat in the
narrative majesty yes everyone knows the
rules about how coronations aren't valid
if the Queen to be is wearing gloves
when grabbing the scepter this ice makes
serious progress on these royal items
and no one in the entire Hall notices it
this is the first time they've seen or
spoken to each other in like a decade
you women can't is there any reason you
can't tell your sister about your powers
now that you're both adults when the
trolls recommended you keep it from her
she was like six falling in love in one
evening montage cliche the guard
obviously sees suspicious activity but
decides Africa would they have been able
to climb a roof this steep we are nearly
in 30 minutes into this 90-minute movie
and while the kingdom and princesses are
pretty well established there's no real
sign of conflict and I honestly can't
tell who the main character is Elsa or
on like this anymore
damn it all is this movie doing that
whole simple misunderstanding that real
people would never have because they ask
questions and have normal human
conversations about a thing she would
rather Encino man her sister than just
tell her the truth
Hans in charge but the kingdom the place
things this loosey-goosey you to think
some other Kingdom would have long ago
taken over this place it's not like
anyone's actually in charge of anything
here so is she empowered now or is she
the villain now horse abandons the hero
for no other reason in the plant cliche
nope sorry
hypothermia this chick is dead we if the
whole land discovered an icy cold winter
that can't go away because you know it's
so cold that the Sun can't melt the ice
then how is there a running stream for
Anna to fall into also if there's a
chance to get even more hypothermia this
is it that would be another department
snowshoes are known for their excellent
comic timing also this is a terrible way
to store bread what size doesn't matter
did the writers just sneak in a size
doesn't matter joke into this kids movie
well good thing these wolves have
evolved to have eyes that can glow on
cue or else humans wouldn't have a
chance
setting it on fire necessary wouldn't
the sheer force of being hit by the
bundle be enough this is like a family
version of the gray too bad Liam Neeson
isn't here to threaten to beat someone
to death over between billfold I'm sorry
even when you're a cartoon you should be
dead gripping a snowy cliff with gloves
at the very least do like wily coyote
and crashing to the bottom of the canyon
with a satisfying poof I like this shot
but we're the far they're going right
now it's completely frozen roll credits
alright is a dick - snowman she's just
met well I can't be upset about a
talking snowman even if I want to be
right after this movie started out with
magical Rock trolls but I can always
just a warm another sin here for the
magical Rock trolls because it's not
like that's gotten any less stupid at
this point that's right come on I mean
you definitely don't remember anything
about Olaf because the magic trolls at
the beginning and surely if you remember
Olaf you'd remember your sister the ice
games you played and getting knocked
unconscious and all of this could have
been avoided in the first place also
when did Elsa's power change from being
able to create snow and ice to being
able to create living conscious beings
out of snow I need volunteers to go with
me to find her oh man but who are you
gonna leave in charge of arendelle
goddess ex machina you should probably
wait out here
what last time I introduced her to a guy
she froze everything impeccable logic I
mean those were way different
circumstances and what is she gonna
extra freeze the already frozen country
if she gets upset this time just
give us a minute okay snowman who has no
idea how the sun's heat would melt him
does have a concept of time so what does
Elsa eat out here or do magical beings
not need food now that's just musical
cheating okay so this isn't the
abominable snowman and you're just
basically gonna take the Ghostbusters
villain name sure they don't call them
marshmallow man but they might as well
why about your hair it's a good thing on
I got hit with the icy blast with
Kristoff around the one guy who's made
friends with the magic trolls and don't
worry they'll be able to fix this how do
you know because I've seen them do it
before and you're not putting two and
two together and realizing she's the
exact same girl somehow hi Sven's family
I like Josh GAD as much as the next guy
but he clearly watched too much ice age
before making this movie his characters
a discount Sid if I ever saw one okay
trolls wait just long enough to come
alive for some reason so Anakin think
Kristoff is crazy
is it the clumpy way he walks I came
here to heal the girl who got struck by
an ice blast but sure let's do a quick
number first god this entire movie only
happens because no one says the obvious
bit they should say at the right time
okay so these trolls are love experts
when did saving people from icy blast to
the head enter the picture only an act
of true love can thaw a frozen heart oh
my god use your ice powers to make a
wall of ice and keep these guys from
doing anything it's that hard all of a
sudden
[Music]
we got no way they ran up those stairs
that fast even the cartoon world they
should have slipped and slid all the way
up to the Stooges sits here and watches
not firing while the Queen slowly
imprisons his buddy make sure she's safe
unnecessary orders hans is suddenly evil
because well we need another 15 minutes
out of this script and also had two
decent guys for her to fall in love with
and this way she doesn't have to make a
choice also wouldnt it be logical for
the ice loving Kristoff to fall in love
with the ice queen
two perfect guys two perfect girls and
the sniveling weaselton guy could have
been the villain trying to overthrow
arendelle instead this movie so focused
on trying to pull the rug out from the
audience and be surprising it loses
common sense you won't get away with
this I already have more of those
amazing doors to a common room that can
lock people in from the outside
lucky Anna came to this room so Hans
could begin his evil plan frozen turns
the flat metal object that can open
doors and start cars into a carrot
because carrots open locked doors now
also how the fuck did he know Anna was
in here also maybe she should be dead by
now
Elsa's ice tends to move quickly in her
heart's been frozen for days now guy who
wants to kill the Queen just stares at
her when she drops to her knees and
turns her back
nature's sword delay from Hans here
that's supposed to happen in older men
act of true love magic takes a long-ass
time to start working after the actual
act of true love I love you
if maureen johnson is suggesting to
Veronica Mars what I think she is then
that beats my fanfiction and rough
sketches Elsa do you think maybe you can
wait till we're not standing out in the
middle of the frozen lake to start
thawing the whole city also Elsa masters
our newfound love magic instantly she
still doesn't know how to use her ice
powers properly went on killing people
I'm calling bullshit on this they were
on a boat the whole time nonsense here
because they are clearly not on a boat
back before the thawing started we never
really got an answer on how her ice
magic managed to create a sentient being
but good I guess we've got ice skating
to do these assholes had no idea Hans
had turned evil that all happened down
at the ice lake in the middle of the
blizzard they couldn't see through but
hey the princess just punched a dude so
yuck it up everyone
I'm pretty sure you can't leave your
boat frozen in the middle of the lake
all winter and then have it work just
fine we're not sure how to end this
thing and just slowly pull back and
swell up the music also an island
kingdom along unseen princess locked
away horse reindeer playfulness wild
scoundrel love interest I swear to god
this movie entangled started out as the
same script
[Music]
that's the sound of the man working on
the chain
[Applause]
the sea was angry that day my friends
like an old man trying to send back soup
in a deli we would your blessing Jesus
cold as ice
[Music]